- So today I'm going to do a few things.
So usually start with
a bit of a motivation
to explain the broader
project in which this all fits
and what is the motivation behind it,
what is the open research
agenda on political lotteries?
Then the initial research
that Ali presented fits in
perfectly as an example,
so I won't go over that again,
but I will talk instead more
about this initial research
from an experiment on
online citizen assemblies,
which is a project coauthored
with Dominik Duell at the
University of Innsbruck
and Anam Kuraishi at the
University of Antwerp.
So I don't need to go
into too much detail here
about the motivation.
We all know that these experiments
with citizen assemblies
whereby randomly drawn citizens
are brought together to deliberate
are growing across the world
in different countries,
are gaining an importance.
And the question is what
we can learn about that.
A particular topic in which
they've been organized is
climate and how we can
address climate change.
There are lots of calls
for and also experiments
with these randomly drawn
citizens assemblies,
but also institutionalizing
them into more permanent
chambers of parliaments.
And so with that shift
where these groups are
sometimes given legislative
initiative or at least
decision making powers
comes an important question.
And that is, what about the parties?
What about the sort of natural
ideological leanings
that people will have?
And what are the incentives
there to build parties?
And the question then becomes
whether all these advantages
that we know exist from
random citizen assemblies
can easily travel to
such a legislative arena
where we know that stakes are very high
and party affiliations come into play.
The broad and general research question
of the broader project
is not just the better,
but really how can lotteries
as part of legislative
or democratic institutions
widen access to governance
to different minorities and
support equality in democracies.
And so when people talk about
democracy and lotteries,
they often go back, way back in time.
Same picture here as we saw
before today of the Kleroterion,
which if I remember well ,
I saw actually in Athens,
you can still see it in the
Museum of the Agora maybe,
of course you can correct me if I'm wrong.
And so people go back to this of course
very prominent example,
we have a lot of recent work
that is very fascinating
on this particular case.
But we know that lotteries were
used in different scenarios.
Italian city republics
are very often mentioned
between the 14th and the 17th century.
But there are others, such
as in Spain, in England,
and in Switzerland at a local
level and many others still.
Lotteries can be found as examples as part
of democratic government
and Republican government
way back in time.
And there's also some
recent work which gives
a lot of examples on this,
mainly theoretically or from
a broader historical overview.
So lotteries were often used
to select office holders,
but then the story goes,
mass elections took over
as more people were getting involved
as this was upscaled.
And so from lotteries,
democracies moved to elections
to organize the way to
select office holders.
And for a lot of people
that are thinking about
what is maybe going wrong
with democracy today,
this element of citizen
participation that was there
by lotteries is what is
really missing today.
But what is not often known
or what is less well known is
that lottery did not
immediately disappear.
And this story is an
important story to tell.
It did not immediately
disappear in modern democracy.
In fact, they were used extensively
throughout democratizing Europe.
And we don't know much about them
in our empirical democratization studies.
And so addressing that
is part of this project
that I will be working
on in the next five years
together with Ali, of course.
So the questions that I ask is,
did lotteries really widen
access to minorities?
And if they did so, how?
Was it maybe the case that
where lotteries were used,
it really enabled
constitution drafting given
that such high stakes were
at play, constitutions,
the shift to democratic government,
which would have consequences
down the line for many years and centuries
as we know post hoc,
what was the interaction with
the party system development
which was happening at the same time?
So what was the interests
of these parties that were
emerging at the time, and
how did that structure,
the way that the lotteries worked,
and are there maybe long-term consequences
for political inequality that
we've maybe underestimated
because we've sort of forgotten
these peculiar procedures.
So the methodology of
the project is historical
to check each natural
experiment separately
and then place that together
with online experiments today
in a comparative perspective.
And you can think of examples
where this happened in one shot cases
as an example of Denmark we saw today,
but it also happened in
more modern legislatures
as we have some work on in the past
where this happened repeatedly over time.
And it's of course particularly
there that you need
to think about party system dynamics
and the dynamics of using
lotteries repeatedly over time
and which actors have an interest
in capturing that process.
So the example today is really
this constituent assembly
in Denmark where you had
lotteries determining
the different committees
who then met and discussed
and prepared the constitution
and the draft of the Constitution.
And the idea is to put all
these different examples
into a comparative
analysis to study the use,
also the reasons for the abolishment
and the effects of
what we call these
lottery based procedures
across countries and time.
And so the important hypothesis
are sort of listed here.
One idea is that they are
really used in context,
I cannot emphasize this enough,
where conflict is really high.
Yeah, if conflict is not that important,
then there are better
and more efficient ways
of organizing political decision making.
So when there's high distrust,
when party systems are splintered,
when it's not clear who the opposition is,
like who belongs to which party maybe,
and when you have huge, for example,
inequalities as you had in
the 19th century, of course,
this is a scenario where
lotteries might be used by actors
and might be successful, I
say might because it depends.
Then the second thing to study is
to think about is whether these lotteries
really opened access
to the decision making
process as we assume
that lotteries do because
that's in their very nature.
By randomly drawing individuals,
you equalize opportunity of access to all,
you strengthen the
minorities who may otherwise
be easily ignored.
So the question there is whether
when you open this access,
are there long-term consequences?
Does that work by leveling
political inequality
in political selection, for example?
Does it work through
the types of decisions
that are made in this legislature?
And how does that translate
into evolution over time?
So the three main hypotheses
are summarized here.
So first, when it's used in
highly conflictual situations,
it might be precisely useful
for enabling collaboration
to exist in the first place.
So for example,
the procedures that we used
in this one-shot fashion
in constituent assemblies,
it might enable party
system development over time
because you have a procedure in place
while these parties emerge.
And thirdly, once these
parties become stronger,
they will prefer a more
efficient procedure
and they might move to
abolish these procedures.
That you can test by looking at these
procedures in repeated
legislative assemblies.
It's important to understand
the long-term effects
on political inequality from this broader
academic point of view
to understand what is really going on
in the long term when
we use such procedures.
So method wise, it's a
lot of data collection
that hasn't been done before.
So it's using information
on 19th century legislators,
the way they voted, the
characteristics they had,
sometimes they weren't
even in formalized parties,
et cetera.
And then for each natural experiment,
the idea is to analyze
each lottery in country
and over time to really
check whether it increased
the diversity of the people involved
in the political debates, did it do that?
And then secondly,
can we show that there
are any long-term effects,
either because it affected the votes
as you saw in the Denmark
case this morning,
or because it enabled
party system development,
or because it affected
long-term inequality.
Now some of these lotteries can
of course be a bit limiting,
which is why we also want
to implement this in
online experiments, why?
Because we can control more
of the aspects of lotteries.
We can of course not go
back in time in history
and change these things,
but to check really whether the idea
that certain mechanisms are going on
also receive support in experiments today.
And I'm finally putting this
all together in a comparative
analysis to inform successful
lottery design today.
And I've given this
talk a number of times,
so I know that you're
going to tell me, but why,
why does this matter?
So lessons from lotteries to today,
why does it matter for today?
If you think about the example
that Ali presented this morning,
you have elected legislators being
randomly assigned to different committees.
And what we saw there was very
little room for deliberation
to really have a strong effect.
But at the same time,
Denmark wrote a constitution,
and the constitution
remains in place today.
So one comment is, well,
elected legislators are very different
from ordinary citizens.
In this constituent assembly,
you have a binding
decision, very high stakes,
you have huge inequalities and conflict,
low levels of trust.
But consensus is really important here.
You will not achieve a
constitution unless you all,
unless this is a broadly
supported process,
you really need consensus.
All the actors involved regardless of
their particular stance on
specific items of this question.
And so this may be very different
from citizen assemblies today.
It may be a particularly hard case
to discover any deliberation effects
because we know that partisan
beliefs are important here.
But actually I would
argue it's very similar
to today's problem about
climate change mitigation,
where you also have huge
inequalities between actors.
Because addressing climate change
will have huge
redistributive consequences.
It's a scenario where a
consensus is very important
for a collective action where
this needs to be a decision
supported by a lot of different actors.
And so we have lessons
to learn from these
legislative assemblies,
lottery holds promises for
this deliberation to work,
but we need to take serious
that the redistributive effects
may encourage strategic behavior.
And you see it in some
ways in the backlash
that some of these assemblies
have had in the past.
So I wanted to give you this overview
to let you know what the project is about,
but also to give a good introduction
of why I will now present
a slightly peculiar,
interesting hopefully, experiment.
So the idea was to model a
present day citizen assembly
in a very abstract way,
but by introducing financial incentives
as you would in a behavioral experiment,
to really understand,
to be able to predict what should happen,
and to really understand
what the mechanism is in different steps.
Here in particular, to
introduce strategic behavior.
So I will go onto that now.
So how do people deliberate
and decide in strategic environments?
Here we apply this to climate
change, collective action.
I mentioned how it's
relevant and important
because of high stakes
and because of the promises
that lotteries give us here
for randomly drawn decision makers.
There are two aspects in this experiment
that are really important for me
in structuring the exercise.
One is that this is a group decision.
A lot of work has not thought
about the fact that this,
or I mean experimental work, I should say,
is a group decision.
And secondly, costs, costs
are also very important.
When you think about citizen assemblies,
you need to think about
how people interpret this
in terms of if has real costs for them.
So in this experiment,
people are allowed to
share if they want to.
It's voluntary.
They're allowed to share their beliefs
and opinions in an
online group discussion.
But I'm controlling certain
parameters of this interaction
to really understand what you
should theoretically predict
or should theoretically
find in such a setup.
And the initial results
that I will tell you about today come
from a pilot experiment that I run
where we find that if you tell people
before going into the
deliberation that a vote
is going to come up
which is costly for them,
it changes the decision making process,
it changes their behavior
and changes the outcome.
So we know a lot about deliberation.
We also know a lot about
how people think about
addressing climate change
from existing literature.
And this is just a slide
with three different important parts
from the experimental literature
on climate change deliberation.
So first of all, an
experimental literature
on citizen assemblies and
within deliberative democracy
is positive, mostly positive,
showing that individuals really learn,
they really intensively deliberate,
they pick up information,
and they successfully
take collective action
against climate change.
There are a few studies
that find no results
or opposite effects, but
overwhelmingly positive evidence.
The thing with these assemblies is
that they're very often advisory.
And so their decision that
they take is not costly
to the people involved,
not directly costly,
because it's not binding,
because it's advisory,
and more things happen down the line.
And what we also know
from this literature is
that the way this conversation takes place
or the quality of this
conversation is really important.
So it has to be well moderated,
people have to be able to
really express their minds,
et cetera.
What the literature also shows is
that if you increase the
complexity of this interaction,
or you ask people to take a
binding decision in a vote
or something like that,
it becomes more difficult to achieve
these beneficial outcomes.
So if we make this decision binding,
that's a scenario where we should really
expect strategic behavior.
And this is a good model
of thinking about new parties developing
in such environments.
The second part of the
literature that is relevant
and important is literature
that looks at climate change mitigation.
And when people support this,
they find a lot of people support
climate change mitigation.
But it really is conditional
on how to what extent today
will be affected themselves.
So they're supportive as
long as the costs are low.
And that is of course related
to their preexisting
economic vulnerability
to these changing measures,
to their ideology, altruism,
egalitarian preferences, and so on.
But what these studies
and the next ones also
ignore is that in these types
of decision making processes
decisions are taken collectively.
So from behavioral experiments,
we also know that we can
think about climate change
as a public bad and people
tend to underinvest in it.
So what is important for us,
given that we know all this,
what is it that we really want to distill?
One, it has to be a group decision.
And the costs have to be substantively,
there have to be costs over
substantively meaningful choices.
So I hope I've now sufficiently
motivated this experiment,
and I will now go into the details
and unleash the critiques.
So our experiment was pre-registered.
It's a pilot that took place in the lab
because it's a pilot and
because we understand
and know that there are a
lot of difficulties involved
with encouraging good deliberation online.
But people came to the experimental lab
and were assigned a workstation
and entered into an online deliberation
with each other over Zoom.
It allowed us to control video,
sound quality, and so on.
But they had an actual interaction online.
It's an incentivized experiment,
which means that after eliciting
their current carbon footprint,
we try to mimic the real
costs in the lab of saying
that you will reduce your pollution,
your individual pollution.
And then the question of course is,
is this manipulation-proof?
Will there be changes to
deliberation and to the outcomes?
So the experiment is incentivized,
it's this type of experiment,
but it's not incentivized to stick
to an original randomly
assigned viewpoint.
That makes no sense
when you're talking about
these types of topics,
you want people to really
express their held opinions
and beliefs about this.
So people are allowed to do that.
And what we randomly
assign is which individuals
are appointed to which groups.
So participants would come into the lab,
they would draw a number, a
small little ball from a bag,
and some of them would be sent home
and some of them entered the experiments.
So people are randomly
assigned to the groups
and to the treatments as well.
Then we use our existing
pollution behavior
as they tell us it is to
stretch out this group
on a scale of income points.
So some stand to gain
or lose more than others
in financial incentives
I mean in this experiment.
The topic is of course also important
because people have to
talk about something
that is substantively meaningful to them.
And here we decided to follow
the UK Climate Assembly
and we used their materials
to make a really brief,
really short distillation
of these materials
and I'll show you later
on either flights or food.
And that is not to say
at all that we think
that individuals can solve climate change
by changing their own behavior.
But what we want is that this deliberation
is substantively meaningful for them.
And that they don't think
of these topics as well,
that's the government's
job, not saying it isn't.
I'm saying it's important
that they deliberate
over something that they
can actually control.
That the costs are meaningful
to them also as well.
Not just a strange
payoff in an experiment.
So how do people then
deliberate on collective action
about climate change?
So this is the basic
structure of the experiment.
Groups of seven were recruited
and they first fill out a survey
to elicit their climate policy preferences
after of course consent
and information forms.
And then they told us about
their current carbon footprint.
We took that and we assigned them
to income points two to six.
And we told them, this is your endowment.
And every two points
is worth an extra pound
in this experiment, took place in the UK.
Now with some probability, however,
climate catastrophe will happen,
and then you'll receive only
one point of that endowment.
Catastrophe happens.
It's bad for everyone.
So how much tax are you now willing to pay
to avoid this catastrophe
wipes out these earnings.
That's what we call the
pre-deliberation platform.
There's a control group
who doesn't talk at all.
There is a treatment group
that goes into deliberation over Zoom.
Because that has to be incentivized too.
They have to come up with a
group statement afterwards.
And there's a strategic
liberation treatment
where the only difference
is that we first tell them,
oh, the next stage is
coming up, by the way.
And that's a vote. Next stage is the vote.
Everyone is told about the vote
if they hadn't been told before.
And when they vote, we take
this tax that they vote for
from this endowment that we gave them.
We also realize the catastrophe
with some probability,
so that if they didn't invest enough,
they have a higher risk of
their earnings being wiped out.
And then we do other
things that are typical
of behavioral experiments
to elicit willingness
to cooperate risk preferences, et cetera
and to make sure we have measures of that
to control for these things.
Okay, where are the
incentives coming from?
After reading the information,
but before the deliberation and voting,
we ask them, what do you think,
which of these five things
do you think should happen?
Nothing.
Low tax or high or the
highest possible tax.
And now we show them, if
these were a real vote,
this is what the outcome would've been.
So this experiment, it's
important to point out,
has a common value by design,
like we designed it that way.
We wanted people to pick a higher tax
because it's protective
against climate change.
It's an insurance, you can
think of it for everyone.
The control group has no
discussion, but before the vote,
that's also important to mention,
everyone knows the distribution
of points at least.
And then finally, an
important note to make is
that one moderator was present,
but was purposely asked to stay neutral.
So the only thing they did
was say, well, this is work,
I'm keeping time.
Maybe they would say,
perhaps you would like to contribute.
And at the end, please
write up a group statement.
What would you expect to see?
Well a greater willingness
to choose a higher tax
from the deliberation effect,
that's what you expect
from these different
theories on deliberation.
And that might be because
their attention is drawn
by reading this information
because they gained information
or because they're persuaded by some
of the individuals that
they're talking to.
Deliberations were very
short, 10 minutes only.
The hypothesis on strategic
deliberation are somewhat different.
So if you know about
the upcoming election,
you introduce incentives
to change this process
because it might be
better for you financially
if you have a different type of outcome.
So it'll change the nature
of the deliberation.
And then in our pre-registered experiment,
we had a number of more
detailed hypotheses,
but I won't go into that too much today.
So first is the control group.
And remember we have this
entry voting and outcome stage.
We expect to see an outcome
that deliberating groups more often vote
for a higher tax as you would see in lots
of these other experiments
taking place across the world.
But in a strategic deliberation,
you should see that they would choose
for either of these two options,
which means that the
total effect is noisy.
So this positive deliberation effect
is sort of decreased
somehow, is disturbed,
and the overall effect,
well we can't know.
And then the mechanism is
something we're still working on.
We're analyzing what people
said in the conversation,
the quality of the deliberation
to sort of really test
which of these three
mechanisms can explain
the deliberation effects.
Should I go over the
sequence of moves once again?
Because I know it's a lot of things.
Also happy to come back to this.
These were the materials,
for example, on flying first,
a small bit, very structured.
This is how much flying matters.
Secondly, technological
improvements might happen,
but that's uncertain.
And then finally,
you can do something by
reducing your demand.
Same for food. Food is
important in pollution.
Technological improvements
may happen and solve things,
but demand from consumers may grow.
So you can do something
by reducing your demand.
Very structured.
Some initial results.
So this is the number of groups we had
and the number of people, 378 in total.
And the distribution across deliberation,
strategic deliberation,
and a control group.
At the top, you see the
distribution in carbon footprints
we forced them into, and underlying that,
you see the distribution
in carbon footprints
they actually had in the lab.
So you see it's not ideal.
We would've preferred better distribution,
but it's also not that bad
in terms of you can see that
group six pollutes more,
has a higher footprint than group two.
This is what they told us,
their initial preferences.
So if they cared only about
the financial incentive,
you wouldn't see this,
you would see very clearly
that the people on the
carbon footprint six
would say do nothing.
And people on carbon footprint two
would say highest reduction,
purely financially,
purely based on financial incentives.
But you don't see this.
You see a mix of things.
What is important to note though,
is that almost no one said,
in our sample at least,
people that were in our lab,
that they want to do nothing.
There were a few of those,
but not a lot of people said do nothing.
Quite a few, however, said lowest please
or low reduction rather
than high or highest.
And this is the results.
So we see the blue dot here,
that deliberating groups
more often vote for the high tax level.
So a high or highest
level as group choices
after having spoken to each other.
But if we break that up between groups
who are deliberating freely
and groups who are told
before that there would be this vote
and their earnings would be
affected in the experiment,
you see a difference.
You see that the deliberating
group is positive,
strategic liberation is
less likely to support it.
And the difference is significant,
the green line between these two
different types of deliberation.
The final thing I want to show
you is I talked a bit about,
we also checked entry
and voting and outcomes.
So this was outcome, this was
the outcome of these groups.
This is at group level.
Here we want to look
at individuals voting.
So among these 370 people,
did they changed their vote
from their original preferences?
And we don't see that if
we leave it unrestricted
in columns one, two, three.
But if we ask, did they
change their votes away from
what they were initially saying
they would choose to either
a high or a highest tax level
as we encourage them to say,
or as the experiment was
designed to encourage them to do,
we do see that it's more likely
that those in the deliberation
treatment move there
and those in a strategic
deliberation less so
restricting the sample of course
to people who did not already have
the highest preference in the first place,
because they cannot be
influenced any further.
So to conclude, compared to the baseline,
and compared to each other,
we see differences between
the type of deliberation.
Deliberation has great outcomes,
but less so when the
deliberation is strategic.
The next step is to analyze the quality
of these deliberations
and to say something about why do we see
this positive effect and what is it
that these people told us in this
or each other, not us directly,
into why they cared about us
and why a decision was so important.
And this is just preliminary
because it's only for parts
of the sample suite, might change.
But we do see that the
quality of the deliberation
as typically measured in the literature
was higher among the non-strategic group
done in a strategic group
on a number of different
arguments such as neutral arguments,
neutral counter arguments,
no interruptions, et cetera.
So in the future,
the plan is to build this
up and to scale this up
either by potentially
bringing these people together
in a larger group and then seeing
what eventually happens
in this larger assembly,
or to dig in more detail
and improve the tests of
the deliberation mechanism.
Another question that I often have
and that I'm still thinking about,
I'm happy to talk about today,
is whether you need to
improve the real life analogy
of these experiments.
A lot of people say, well,
deliberation can just not
be measured in 10 minutes.
I say, well these results
actually show that you can,
I mean there clearly is a difference,
even from as little as 10 minutes.
So I'm still thinking about this part.
I'm not saying it's not
important. Thank you.
(applause)
- [Ali] So this is neat,
and I actually think you
have more in the qualitative,
like the transcripts of the deliberation,
or you could learn a lot.
And so my question would
be in the strategic group,
do you see evidence of, okay,
I have to convince everyone to agree,
so I know I'm not gonna get the tails.
Like we're gonna have to
come up with a happy medium,
or do you see more bullying
in the strategic group?
Does anyone say like, well,
I'm gonna be hurt the most,
but okay, I'll compromise
so we can come to a coordination,
like the language and the tactics
that people use to deliberate,
can you look at the text of
the groups and see differences?
Like what do you see?
- So thank you Ali.
That's a really good one.
So we're looking at this by using the DQI,
as is common in the literature,
but we're also looking at
whether they've used keywords
such as election, majority,
most important preference,
things like that.
And you know, from a first glimpse,
not everything has been coded yet,
but it does seem to be the case that
that more often is part of
the language, for example.
So yeah, that's an important one.
- [Dmitri] Thank you. Dmitri Landon, NYU.
It seems like the strategic
deliberation treatment,
kind of the plausibility of
the strategic deliberation
treatment kind of relies on the subjects
buying into the frame.
And so my question is, do you
have exit interview questions
that give us a sense of whether
they did buy into it or not?
How much did the frame
ultimately matter to them?
- Did you say exit survey?
- Yes.
- I'm not sure it really answers
this particular question.
We did have an exit survey actually
that we did not incentivize
as is common in citizen
assemblies as well.
We did not find any differences.
People did not tell us that
they were more trustworthy
or that they were happy
with the process, et cetera.
- [Dmitri] What I mean is
did your subjects really
understand themselves
as making a choice with respect
to climate change policy?
Or did they understand
themselves as just playing a game
that has, as you said, there is like,
I don't know if it's the dominant strategy
in the game or not, but whatever it is
to choose a high tax.
So that's the question.
If they did understand
themselves as really
choosing a climate change policy,
presumably we would interpret
these results somewhat
differently than if we
thought this is just
a diverting exercise.
- That reminds me,
I believe we also asked about
if you're now thinking
about implementing this
really into your own life,
how would you think about reducing,
what are sort of the efforts you can make?
If I'm not mistaken, it was
one of our exit questions too.
But can't tell you yet
what it was exactly.
- [Dmitri] Another question I have is,
have you thought about
the possibility of a joint
payoff version of the
strategic deliberation game?
So you have a binding policy choice,
but their payoffs are
individual private payoffs.
So one thing you might think about is
having a joint payoff, group payoff,
see how that alters the deliberation.
- Well the tax that they were
paying is progressive though,
so the higher polluters
are more intensively taxed
in any case if the tax level
is that is chosen is higher.
So it partly addresses that, not entirely.
- [Dmitri] That's not quite--
- We can talk about it.
- [Dmitri] If you think about,
part of the value of
doing a joint payoff is
that a joint payoff would
enable them to, again,
see this as a more
cooperative kind of exercise.
- But there's a lot going
on in the experiment,
but we do have the shock
of climate catastrophe.
So sometimes it happens
that if you choose a level
of tax that is too low, you
get a draw, which is bad,
and everyone's payments
are reduced to one.
I mean, in this particular stage, yeah.
- [Audience Member] I
think I just have a sort of
an interpretive question.
So you refer to it as a tax,
but at one point you also
refer to it as insurance.
Is it presented to them as insurance
or is it presented to them as a tax?
Partly I think this speaks
to the collective dimensions
of what they think they're doing.
So you mentioned...
You stressed that you
were not presupposing
that there are individual
solutions to climate change.
But I think that if you think
that you can buy insurance
against climate change,
that's precisely imposing a
kind of an individual solution,
not in the sense of like,
I can solve climate change,
but rather I can buy myself out
of the consequences of climate change.
I just wonder how you present it to them.
- Experiments like that have been done.
And what you see is the
typical free rider problem.
It's very hard to get collective action.
People tend to not put
enough into this common fund
to protect and to buy investment.
That's why it was so
important that they would talk
to each other and make
a decision collectively,
as in a vote,
a vote which is decided by plurality rule,
which is binding for everyone,
also the people who did not vote for this.
So I think that's precisely
what the experiment tries to add to,
experimental literature
is already out there.
- [Brenda] Did you say you
had results on interruptions,
who interrupts?
Is it the men,
because there's large literature,
especially in like the parliamentary
committees about like who
interrupts in senior politicians
and gender,
so who was interrupting and
did it vary across the groups
and what were the interruption results?
- So we're measuring this as
part of an item of the index.
So we're looking at the
number of interactions.
I often get this comment though,
and I think it's absolutely important,
but we randomly assigned our participants
and we didn't really study
this aspect of the question,
which is a very important one,
but it's not one we really addressed.
I mean, it's randomly assigned.
We might look at whether
there are differences.
We could do that.
I mean in the final outcomes, right.
Whether it affected the conversation,
depending on these types
of characteristics as well.
Even though when I look
at the characteristics
of these groups, they
don't significantly differ
in their composition on these types
of factors that we collected.
- [Brenda] I just meant in
general, like descriptively,
like across the groups,
do you see like one specific
type of person interrupt more?
- Sometimes. I mean, yes.
Like I can give you examples,
but I don't know how systematic it is.
This happens absolutely.
- [Federica] Thank you, Brenda.
Federica Carugati from KCL.
This is just a clarification
and it might be driven by
the fact that I was trying
to like keep up with the
presentation of the whole project
before you went into this
particular sort of a bit.
And I'm wondering, did I
understand correctly that
you are planning to look at historical
and online experiments at the same time?
And I'm really interested in that.
And if you can just speak a
little bit more about like
what's the hunch and what you expect
to see in this comparative scenario,
that'd be great, thank you.
- Thank you, great question, thank you.
I can get to be passionate
about the project.
So for example, in the Denmark case
that Ali presented this morning,
a comment we get a lot is,
well these were five groups
and what can you say from the fact
that this happened only once.
We say well a lot
because this was a
really important context,
a really consequential case,
and it should be studied.
We shouldn't just pick it because
it allows better statistics.
But putting that into a
comparative perspective
can really help us to draw
out some of these mechanisms
that the historical cases do
not allow us to investigate.
So does it matter how large the group is?
Does it matter whether these
are seven people or 70 people?
Does it matter by the types
of decision rule they use?
As we know, as Ali said this
morning from electoral law
should matter quite a lot
for the different outcomes you get.
- [Dmitri] Thank you, I want
to think a little bit more
about the comparison of the kinds
of arguments that you saw people use
in the strategic liberation treatment
in the non-strategic treatment.
So in the strategic liberation treatment,
you have a game, right?
And in that game, I don't know, as I said,
I don't see the payoffs.
So it's a dominant strategy,
is that right for them to
be preferring the high tax?
Is it a dominant strategy for them
to be preferring the high tax?
- Yeah, I mean it's a trade off for them,
in which the people who
are taxed more highly
should be preferring a lower tax.
- [Dmitri] Fine, but it's a game,
and what they want to do is to incentivize
their fellow players to
make one set of choices
as opposed to another set of choices.
And in that game, presumably,
they're going to be using arguments
that speak to their payoffs
as you have given to them in the game.
Whereas in the non-strategic treatment,
that set of considerations
is off the table.
The only relevant considerations
presumably, if any,
are going to be frame
related considerations,
which is to say it's climate change
or do we support higher, lower,
or sort of more aggressive
or less aggressive policy in
response to climate change.
So in some sense, it's not surprising
that you will see very
different kinds of arguments
that would be on the table
in the two kinds of
treatments, am I wrong?
- But eventually the
decision remains the same,
whether you know about it
before you talk to these people
or afterwards, the decision
that you have to take
as a group is the same, the
incentives are the same,
the financial incentives are the same.
So the difference is whether
you figure this out
before you talk to people
and whether that changes the types
of communications they
have with one another
or whether you only
realize this afterwards.
- [Dmitri] But the deliberation treatment
is the treatment without
the payoffs, is that right?
- Same payoffs.
So there's some aspect I'm missing.
So what's the difference between
the strategic deliberation treatment
and the deliberation treatment?
- The only difference is that you know it
before you enter the Zoom room.
So we tell you everything
about this election
that you will have about a policy option
before you go into the Zoom room
in the strategic treatment.
Whereas we only tell you this
after you've been in the Zoom room
in the normal just regular
deliberation treatments.
In terms of financial incentives
and payoffs, et cetera,
everything stays the same.
And we also have the control
group, same incentives.
The only difference is
they don't talk at all.
- [Dmitri] So what was your explanation
for the differences in the
arguments that you're seeing?
- Well we need more support
from measuring the mechanism,
but I am buying into this idea that
deliberation is going on
and there is an exchange
of views and people either
spend more attention on something,
maybe they're really persuaded,
even though they don't
tell us they're persuaded
in exit surveys, or maybe
it's the information
that we're represented with
and that they have
processed in a different way
when the group is in a normal
deliberation environment
versus a strategic one
where they know this
will have consequences
for the payoffs and the experiments.
- [Ali] Very quickly.
- [Audience Member] Sorry, would you just,
your answer here about
strategic interaction
made me think about the Denmark example.
So a question I was sort of left with,
and maybe we don't know enough about it,
why did they divide up into five groups?
It didn't seem like they were specialized
committees, they were
debating the entire document
in each group.
And what's interesting is if you imagine,
if you can control the
deliberation of one group,
who is the decision maker,
then all of a sudden the
stakes are very different
compared to if there are four other groups
who are all doing the same decision.
That changes the strategy
because being decisive,
steering your group to
one decisive conclusion
would be different than for other ones.
So basically what I'm thinking
of is why don't you try
to mimic the structure
of the Denmark example?
It goes beyond this.
If you're trying to test some
of these strategic mechanisms,
it seems like the context having
a very different structure might have some
of these knock on effects
when you think about
the other groups who are also deliberating
on the same question.
- That's one possibility
and an important one.
And that's why I also wanted
to really present a framework
because it really fits into that.
I think it's also important
to keep the research on topic.
Like it matters because today we're trying
to get good outcomes from
these deliberative groups.
We don't have to necessarily assume
that they will be manipulated,
but we can learn from these past cases
and find out whether
maybe sometimes they were
or what the reasons were
why they were perhaps less successful
than some of the other examples we had,
and to really understand the context
and how it influences the
quality of deliberation.
- [Ali] Thank you very much.
(applause)